all right I want to tell you how I got
my super powers through fatherhood I was
working a job I hated okay and I don't
know if anyone here ever worked the job
they hate it has anyone here I will work
the job they hate it okay good
cuz I'm not alone and I have something
to confess and I don't want you guys to
judge me feels like a safe space this is
a safe space okay good okay I was
working the job I hated my manager and I
were not getting along okay I was
sitting in my car looking in the
rearview mirror trying to figure out
what's friend I could call to call in a
bomb threat so I didn't have to go back
in the building okay this this this was
having a lot of issues for me I was
having a lot of issues at my job and I
come home every day from work and my
wife would ask me the same question and
when you hate your job this is the worst
question anyone can ask you
she'd say hey babe how was your day and
I'd say are you bringing up old stuff I
just left there I don't want to think
about that place again see we were
spending about 40 percent of my income
on childcare we had one child and we
were pregnant with our second child and
we were trying to figure out how we were
gonna fix this whole thing of this money
situation and she said hey babe I got a
great idea I said what's up she said uh
I think you'd be a great stay-at-home
dad I was like why would you say
something like that
she said because babies like you I was
like no they don't she was like no they
do like you and and I think it would be
great for our children to see what love
looks like coming from a father okay so
I had issues with issues with this
because I haven't seen a lot of
stay-at-home dads before and I I thought
men would judge me so get this I said
this please don't be offended I said
this I said you know that sounds boring
and uh what do stay-at-home moms do all
day anyway she smiled at me a smile only
a woman full of knowledge can smile and
said well this sense this should be easy
for you and it will save us some money
it seems like a no-brainer fast forward
six months I'd been a stay-at-home dad
for about a week I was standing in my
bathroom looking into the mirror crying
tears running all down my face my
one-and-a-half year old was banging on a
bathroom door because I locked them out
you know crying tears running down his
face and my newborn was in the bassinet
crying tears running down his face I
looked at myself in the mirror and I
said which one of your friends can you
call a call in a bomb threat man we
gotta get out of here
see I had traded my manager for my
children I didn't know what I got myself
into I thought I knew everything about
being a stay-at-home parent and in fact
I knew nothing at all because even
though my manager was a was well at
least my my children were a lot cuter
than my manager they were just as
demanding my foot
what had I gotten myself into I thought
I knew everything about being a
stay-at-home parent in fact I knew
nothing I thought that all I had to do
was feed them or change their diapers
and they'd be fine like I really thought
that that's that's it
Sesame Street on TV keep them distracted
apple sauce in a bowl milk in a bottle
they'd be fine but if you leave children
alone they'll get into just a little bit
of mischief where is the powder
well what where did you put it with wit
where did it who did it you know what
else I thought I knew about being a
stay-at-home parent I thought that all I
had to do was take him to the park once
a week because if I took him to the park
once a week they'd be fine in fact I
knew nothing at all okay if you take
kids to park every day then that means
they get dirty of the every day if they
got dirty every day they need baths
every day if they got baths every day I
just don't think you understand see
having two kids under two you end up
changing over 20 dirty diapers a day
okay and if you give them a bath that's
just more nakedness and a higher
probability of getting peed on and no
one likes getting peed on even if it's
from a baby but I read this article by
father Lee which cites a survey done by
two detergent companies Oh lamomam
personals and they did this study and
it's said that at two hours a day
prisoners get more outside time than
children that convicted me and so we
went outside
[Music]
see I knew nothing about being a
stay-at-home parent and once I embraced
the fact that I knew nothing I'd begin
to learn from my new managers and I
always was told that is as a
stay-at-home parent you get no sleep or
as a parent in general you get no sleep
but that's not true because if you sleep
when they do you actually can get some
sleep you know what else I thought as a
stay-at-home parent I thought I knew
that the best way to teach kids right
from wrong was to discipline them
because that would make sure they
understood right from wrong the pain the
fear that would teach them but the truth
is the best way for me to teach my
children right from wrong is to teach
them take out a whiteboard and draw
pictures and make connections that they
can understand how was the best way a
lot of these images you're seeing a
coming from my youtube channel believe
from Father huh I documented the
misadventures of being a stay on that
and it's not perfect is this showing
that um I'm trying you know and I'm not
trying to be an example but just proof
that it's possible for whoever else is
doing this you know what I also know
about being a stay-at-home parent I knew
that children needed love but I just
didn't know what love looked like it
turns out putting diapers on your head
and play fighting into the kids fall
asleep is a great way to love your kids
so I was learning a lot but it's not all
fun and boogers is it
I asked a group of stay-at-home parents
was the hardest thing the the thing they
underestimated most about being
stay-at-home parents and they said that
the loneliness was one of those things
not having someone else to talk to
feeling inadequate feeling selfish for
wanting meat on in nursery rhymes suck
like really mary had a little lamb is
cool the first couple times but after
all these years on repeat you wonder why
Mary just saying make herself a wall
skirt and have lamb chops you know what
I'm saying
the one thing I underestimated most was
the emotional fatigue see I was an
artist so I'd write songs for other
artists because that's how I made money
from home but when you're with your kids
all day you become emotionally tired and
that means all your creativity comes
from your emotions so you just tapped
out you're done so you become done with
time in that time timetables timeout
time like to cook with all types of time
you're just done you had no time for
anything and some people are done with
their spouse as a stay-at-home parent
because the spouse just doesn't get it
I was talking to a friend of mine he
said I'm man I come home from work
drawers I the drawers are open clothes
hanging outside the drawers the kids are
still in their pajamas and it can't be
that hard to have dinner ready when I
get home right
start to freak out you know I'm saying
like he was trying to confide in me I I
said you have no idea what you're
talking about she wakes up every morning
tired from the night before a baby
attached to her breast dropping this kid
off at school and taking this one to the
park laundry piles up to the skies he
has a conversation on the phone for
hours with your mom about God knows what
takes the dog you want it for a walk and
nobody died bro she kept your kids alive
all day that's hard I had become an
advocate for stay-at-home parents why
because finally I was standing in their
shoes because when you stand into
someone else's shoes you see the world
from a different perspective and when
you start to take steps it feels like
baby steps wobbling but then they turn
into stomps and you start making
footprints for the next generation to
walk in so we're walking on a certain
path as parents we're all in this
together every no one can deny that
family is one of the biggest foundations
in anyone's life and we're all walking
on this path and we're we're pulling
these thickets out of the way in these
storms making it easier for the ones
coming after us it turns out parenting
has a lot more to do with landscaping
and learning more than teaching and the
best thing to do is to show up for class
be present is what I learned as a
stay-at-home dad and let your presence
be a gift
[Laughter]
this was me coming home from tour one
day I thought that the father was
supposed to pursue the child but it
turns out the father makes himself
present and the children run after him
and that right there is a superpower and
that right there my friends is
everything thank you
[Applause]